let's see if we can shed some light on
the alternative
minimum tax which is also one of the
most confusing aspects of taxation
in the u.s but hopefully this this video
will will clarify things a little bit so
let's go back to that example from the
first video of the person making a
hundred thousand dollars and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to calculate
the amt the alternative minimum tax for
that person and then we're going to see
what happens from there so alternative
minimum tax for someone making a hundred
thousand dollars so what i've drawn
right over here this applies if you make
less than three hundred thousand dollars
the first 47 000 or so is exempt when
you're calculating the alternative
minimum tax so for this person making a
hundred thousand dollars we're just
going to have to consider the balance
above forty seven thousand four hundred
fifty so a hundred thousand
minus forty seven thousand four hundred
fifty would be what it would be fifty
it would be 52 000 let's see this would
be so this amount right over here is
going to be 52 000
and then 6 or
550 if i did my math correct that's a
hundred thousand minus forty seven
thousand four hundred and fifty and what
the alternative minimum tax says is
whatever you are above this exemption
above this forty seven thousand four
hundred fifty exemption you're just
going to pay a flat 26
on that amount and if this person had
made over 70 175 000 it would have been
a flat 28 but let's not go there just
complicates things and these things can
get arbitrarily complicated
and if the person made over three
hundred thousand they would have to use
the 28 percent and this zero this
exemption would disappear but once again
let's not over complicate it let's just
focus on this person so this person has
to pay 26 of
hundred 52
fifty which would be
so it is point two six
times
fifty two thousand five hundred and
fifty gives thirteen thousand six
hundred sixty three
so 13
that is equal to 52
times 26
so this would be the alternative
alternative minimum tax calculation this
13 000 you're like hey that's not so bad
do i pay this above and beyond the 21
000 that we calculated in the first
video and you know how does this work
out and the answer is no
you the the the irs or your account
would look at both of these numbers and
you would pay the higher of the two so
in this situation your regular taxes are
higher than your alternative minimum tax
so you would just pay your regular taxes
now this does come into play
in situations well one if someone is
making a ton of money the amt is
probably going to be the larger number
but it in general be the larger number
if this person has a lot of deductions
so let's say they made a hundred
thousand dollars but they're able to
take 10 grand off because they have
they have mortgage interest that they
can deduct maybe they have all sorts of
other crazy deductions so that their
actual reported income to the irs
becomes i don't know well maybe it
becomes nothing maybe they're able to
deduct everything so that with the
regular taxations it goes down the
reported income when i say deductions
remember i'm not deducting taxes i'm
reporting income so they're able to keep
taking things off of this until
eventually well i won't say nothing
maybe the reported income becomes eight
thousand three hundred and fifty dollars
in which case the regular taxes would
only be 835 dollars and in this
situation they would have to pay the 13
663 and that's the whole point of the
amt is because you had the situation
where people had all these deductions
and were able to get out of paying taxes
even though their income was pretty high
so they had this alternate calculation
to just make sure that people do pay
some taxes